welcome to this video this is obviously
a bit different I'm trying something
that I never tried before on video I'm
playing against the computer I recently
saw that Jerry French as network he had
played this computer here on chess calm
and yeah well a couple of days ago when
it was really late late in the day or
early however he what to call it and
they had already had a couple of glasses
of wine I tried to beat this thing and
it didn't really work out too well this
computer is not especially great you see
him who play it that top engine is
better but it's still a tough opponent
and I figured I could try to play a
couple of games against the team in this
is 5 - time control 5 minutes and 2
second increment yeah people like to
like those videos when Jerry posted them
so I thought I could give it a go so on
okay we have a goon fault here with
Bishop g5 you know it's not the best of
choices against the computer really my
King is slightly awkward on e2
it's a perfectly normal line but you get
the computer you want to have a safe
King position so that you're not blunder
anything stupid
yeah exchanging Queens is also normally
a good idea but I don't really see maybe
rupee one can be five could be an idea
okay here right it prevents it it's a
bit weird this it thing but no
interesting this I didn't expect
okay I need to fight for the a file of
course but it seems that here why it
should be a comfortable at least yeah as
mentioned I had played a couple of games
against the computer in this after
midnight match and it proved to be a
really tough
the typical computer phenomenon it
doesn't blunder anything of course and
if you do anything remotely stupid it
will punish you in terms of tactics I
mean okay but do we have a pretty this
is a pretty decent end game
I have good set a good Center c7 is
slightly weak okay
however how do I actually make progress
and move like CF is can you see can you
sacrifice no I could get a knight to be
fire this would actually be nice maybe I
can try that okay it tries to prevent
that yeah anyway anyway if you yeah
exactly this C pawn move is not exactly
great for black if I play rook v1 c4 c4
probably look a 7 now this looks a bit a
bit awkward
hmm
interesting I don't really know rook b1
b5 C form no I can take on c4 with the
night this should be at least okay for
black hmm how do I get anywhere here
maybe prevent b5 for the moment and go
to D - yeah nitrate I would actually
like that I don't mind at all
okay interesting I have the only open
file so I don't think I'm in any sort of
danger here look 8th phone
okay that could be it could be okay
yeah I saw tonight see for here I
expected that night see for takes on a
for Knight b6 checking his six night xd7
mr. a3 a3 no I've not see five night b3
that's not on he needs to recapture and
then I play I play King the tomb and
approach the apron mmm I've see for as
long I think this is a good endgame
actually a three days this check of
course okay and now I need to approach
and I have C form oh okay okay okay
d5 is not good but I can okay I can I
can no no it didn't it didn't I cannot
do that it is this it thing go here well
if I go see what about c4 is this it's
this terrible for me hmm
getting getting a pony a to d5 should be
it should be okay really
you should be for this I didn't
appreciate
with this might become this might become
very tricky now hmm that's bad that's
bad really g5f for is the is the threat
now and I don't know what to do against
that I came to wave 3 but then he will
have it will have two parts ah that sets
that's bad
King b3 - III coming
yeah I only got 10 seconds as well you
know it takes takes on a 42 III okay
okay now the second pawn but I wait wait
wait we have here wrong the wrong wrong
colored Bishop is in effect can I
somehow somehow use this if he he has
got the H pawn left which is the worst
possible pawn to have with this dark
square bishop maybe I can draw this this
actually maybe maybe the King can
somehow be activated I don't see it at
the moment if - I just sacrifice and I
have the I have the drone that's cool
maybe I can draw this I really don't see
win at the moment and it's increment so
it cannot win on time I mean it's
theoretically possible of course but wow
that's a cool cool escape I really think
it's it wrong
there is no way for me to actually force
that right this is the endgame I really
need to I need really need to those do
those back and forth moves
yeah you can offer a draw I can't man I
can try that but the computer I don't
think it has an operator I'm not sure
the computer was certainly refused yeah
it did yeah that's not too too thrilling
but what can you do I'm glad to have a
drop to be honest this was a very very
critical endgame probably a lost endgame
and draw is really really good now there
is no there is no way really to enforce
the draw
yeah no no no the King approaches maybe
it is still still lost what the heck
it's still it's lost what they've uptick
I really this is this is really bad
Wow how did I lose this it's all was it
lost I'm not really really weird
and then it's really lost yeah the King
can invade I have nothing against that
really why are many many in the exact
right moment that there is this six
maybe yeah I cannot analyze here but not
I'm really not sure okay I'm going for a
rematch let's see this was a bit of an
unlucky loss okay let's see with like
how do you get get the position you want
yeah you want the close position
I'm trying to do that also try to get
the computer out of its it's book so
that it might make some some setup
mistakes opening some some strategical
opening arrows let's put it that way
okay I want I want a very closed
position and I want ideally speaking I
want to bishops against Knight and yeah
like that that's not too good too bad if
I take here if you take my hand my takes
on c6 now but but okay I can take on b2
so this is actually okay and now I'm
getting a phone call okay to switch that
off okay if I go c5 now which I would
like to do that's night b5 but okay this
cannot be so terrible the question is
should I even just move the knight to f6
maybe Queen b6 is also possible but this
maybe not Gio Bishop g4 okay still the
look so this looks like the most natural
way to play okay more okay the computer
might play a five
okay Jim I could play a five for myself
which looks yeah
like very ugly but how do I actually 26
otherwise
kingi seven I could play so that after a
five I can capture if I've from me it's
just very ugly I really don't want to do
that okay now it wants to play a five
okay and I'll retreat
okay so hmm should I go a six here I
guess this is not yeah but the night the
night is really a pest year on me five
maybe I can start with Ruby eight here
where's that Queen g5 mmm okay I'll do
this first so I'm sure I can actually
move the king but okay I wanted to play
rook e8 King f8 but I'm asking myself if
this is really helping me I probably I
need to connect group so he's going to
play or it is going to play before at
some stage okay here I must play g6
Knight a5 I really don't want to face
here or is this just running into a
possible night at five maybe yeah but
still I need to do it probably
okay so at least I have an idea
what I'm going to do aim for here is the
computer has got this very rare
stupid-looking f3 Bishop and I would
like to get an endgame with with the two
knights against Bishop and tonight or
similar types with Knights exchange so
just night against Bishop this would be
quite ok for me it's not overwhelming or
anything but I can I could could live
with that very very easily okay here
yeah I have this pressure against the
b-pawn and I cannot I cannot do much
don't have many active possibilities I
could go a 5 to initiate some more
exchanges a 5 yeah but it might play
Knight c2 we are this is not good
I don't really know g3 maybe we should -
as planned
I'm a bit unsure how to how to continue
him yeah and not worse or anything but
I'm I don't really I don't really know
how to make any sort of progress okay
well I can just recapture with the pawn
that's not a big deal but the computer
might go to h3 this could in fact be a
problem yeah the knight on this seven
sir as a piece that it's not doing
anything really very tricky is still
this was my idea I know it looks passive
but at least the knight is doing
something no I wanted to try to triple
on b3 yeah yeah yeah I came Knight f5
that is in fact
something to to be cautious about mm
tweenage 8 what a move should I do that
age six was under fire okay so we get
one night exchanged but of course the
computer enters with the B shirt which
is not which is not so great I can take
on b3 though this is really a problem I
don't see it at the moment
mmm okay what is what is the threat but
the sting think doing the bishop here
yeah yeah this was clear but I don't I
didn't see the concrete Queen c7 as this
so dangerous Wow
they are computer chess computer chess
takes Queen Queen here's medium well now
tough very tough I had a pretty good
entire computer position pretty pretty
good
I don't really know I mean maybe it is
maybe this is lost I don't know it's
very tricky Queen a5 c7 I don't really
know if I can do anything against it can
I do something besides g5 and I'm
probably probably I'm gonna do two
computer logic if it gives up b3 it's
probably probably just to win okay but
they're interesting games let's let's do
one or two more yeah people are
suggesting I should should add more time
but I think the time is it's okay I mean
I don't I don't mind that really if you
get do you just need a bit of increment
to make sure that you're not going to
lose on time okay I'm playing this
reddit London simply because against the
computer somewhat simpler positions are
often a good choice okay pt.2 probably
if Knight c3 runs into 95 on or
something like that which looks a bit a
bit awkward okay I want to play Bishop
d3 but I don't want to be a rest by
night before so I'm trying to prepare
that okay 95 maybe a computer wants to
go f5 so possible
okay so should I go maybe even here I am
a five is ridiculous then because I take
Wow it lets me take on d5 that's that's
somewhat surprising okay I'm going to do
that simply because the more static that
position becomes the more favorable it
gets for the human player it's simply
this our computer logic in a way still
applies okay so I have somewhat weak
pawns on d6 and d5 that I can play
against how do I continue though night
on B three looks misplaced yeah it
really does
but if I move it the stormy Knight f5
coming I would lie I'd like to have it
on c3 of course okay maybe just just
some routine moves and then see what
what happens okay computer is playing a
5 so I'm going to reroute this this
Knight to c3 as I had the head plan
anyway an interesting way to to cover
things from the side hmm
amazing so what is coming here b5 no no
probably not probably not the night one
f3 is also not doing much maybe maybe
here Knight you want to D 3 something
like that could be an idea well it's
bishop the bishop here is not exactly
great
maybe Knight G 1 e 2 F 4 this could be
an idea actually
but you always know I can do that okay
so this this was this was a good
maneuver it made the computer retreat
two is six
now here this is a good square let's see
now it looks nice but what exactly am i
doing next that it's not clear to me I
am taking s s s useless maybe two before
anyway oh this is surprising they could
not be five what is the reply look
somewhere look at the ED no okay bloody
tactics
yeah that's that's a that's a shame
really
hmm might be three or night c4 even yeah
that's that's really really tough iam
against this and the end this bloody
machine you make one one little one
little mistake and then you're already
in trouble this is already a really bad
position from c6 that could activate the
night and it's really tough now to to
even yeah maybe I can do that
we should 5s d5 hanging yeah don't want
to get into I need to get rid of the
night this is priority absolute highest
priority oh I completely forgot about
this oh yeah g5 if it displays g5 and
traps the bishop what a bad game now it
was actually a pretty good game until I
played the scrap here Wow ah yeah that's
just e5 I just planned that the bishop I
must play h2 and then it's still tough
but it's yeah just bad him
yeah I had a pretty good position
especially a versus a comp but I
night-night b5 allowed Knight to a5 and
this is just terrible just terrible this
is a pretty good anti computer position
I think because it's so blocked maybe
it's still night a for you or something
hard to tell
okay I'll play one more
let's see maybe a French exam the
opening is really very important you
have to compute assembly for the
position type you'd like to have a
pretty close position yeah that's a good
move for a computer just opening up
things even if it is maybe not the most
ambitious line and it's not bad as well
but it's better to have this kind of
position for the computer then a very
closed duel in one of those long thin of
a main lines or let's say I probably
would have played the sidelines anyway
okay try to get rid of this Bishop him
okay yeah that that has some promise
this position unless I'm directly
clobbered on my king I came see for mr.
smooth at the moment I'd love to get in
my to see for viously screen b5 though
I'm not sure Knight f5 my playbook b5 I
don't want to play b6 really okay I do
that and hope that c4 has no move for
him this C for was not played should I
go Knight to g6 yeah I guess I should
get this temple yeah almost the temple I
won now probably the bishop needs to
move and now Knight to f5
going to see father Wow
does that take it what is the what is
the point
queen h7 then queen g4 hmm okay do I
want just h5 maybe Queen f3 and yep
still let's block it
okay and now it's there it's there
Queen g4 Queen g4 Queen f7 probably okay
well this is hanging I can also just
take on edge strong okay I'm doing that
trying to keep it simple it's it really
just it wants to take g7 right that's a
greedy greedy computer yeah butchy it
looks like it's really really a chicken
move here I probably does a chicken move
but still I don't I don't see something
bad happening at the moment okay I'm
taking this I Knight to c4 I am
okay
at least I know what I want this is
always good and chess if you know what
you want to reach I'd like to get the
the the heavy pieces off all of them and
if I manage that I'm actually winning
this game but I'm not sure if I will
manage okay probably I need to improve
this a bit okay okay rook e1 rook e8 if
we take everything off I have this this
perpetual only one maybe this is what I
need to be content with okay
the computer is I can give this to the
the checks here now
Queeny six assaults on 26s may be the
easiest way to go wow I cannot believe
that I'm not winning here this must be a
win with all those structural advantages
for the night the night here how do I do
it actually get this is this is this is
very nice that cannot the comb comb
cannot move not ship oh this is what I
get I get the press tape or now and the
big mistake
yeah I promote here anyway I'm I'm going
back to to secure my kingside the a
porno promote on its own yeah yeah no
problem
I can I can be be patient here
okay so I can also just first protect
this and now the King even must retreat
go here and g5 even er so the King and
that's useless kind of I can't just
promote now so I get a win after all
wow that's good wouldn't would have felt
bad to lose all the games and they were
they weren't so clear at these parts of
them
yeah the computer has no resigned
function I believe maybe if it's just
made next month long or something like
that okay
yeah the the the move a for really gave
it completely away I think it should be
a win anyway but would have been
considerably more difficult of course
here we come and I'll get another Queen
just as easy as possible
Oh at least one win okay now it I think
a for a for Aliyah if what gave it gave
it completely away but normally it
shouldn't really exchange Queens I mean
the the Queen exchange leads to a very
bad end game and maybe queen d3 or
anything I don't know I mean you cannot
really exchange Quincy and and a form
but a form makes it much easier really
yeah maybe it is possible maybe I can
just go to a four and take the pawn but
like white also uses his King to I check
the pawns yeah I hope you enjoyed this
this match it's always a bit weird to
fight a computer but okay at least
against the somewhat weaker ones once in
a while you can actually scroll win
alright thanks for watching